hello so you've started neo2 or maybe
you've been playing and are dying to
much whatever your background I'm here
to outline in greater detail the most
significant new systems and mechanics
added to vo2 as well as offer tips to
help you better understand how to
utilize them I also got some general
combat tips here to help you get back up
to speed
worth noting neo2 is built on the
foundations of the first game which
means it's basic systems like weapons
stances armor weight and key all
function the same I've avoided going too
much into detail about those subjects as
they're generally obvious or are
explained in the opening tutorial take
courage recover key if you're a veteran
of the first game and have noticed that
Neo two's handling of key feels oddly
different it's because adjustments were
made to how fast it replenishes a
characteristic you could now impact when
you level up new to the sequel is the
courage stat which affects your
characters key recovery speed it's not
enough to spec points into heart anymore
you actually need to split the
difference between the two to get your
character precisely where you feel
comfortable these are both stats you
should invest in right away to improve
your odds of survival remember the key
pulse ah yes the key pulse out of all
the mechanics from the first game it's
the most critical the key pulse is a
maneuver that allows you to restore some
of the key you've expended from
attacking or dodging to perform a key
pulse press r1 the moment light gathers
around you after an attack the more
precise your timing the more key you'll
gain back you'll know you've executed it
perfectly time to keep pulse when a
swirling white energy gathers around
your character it's paramount to use key
pulses during fight as the extra key it
gives you can be a lifesaver when you're
cornered especially against bosses it's
also necessary when purifying yokai
realms which are small areas produced by
yokai enemies that enhance their
strengths and slow your key regeneration
rate a key pulse can instantly
extinguish a yokai realm from the field
which becomes even more important inside
the dark realm where yokai roams are
even deadlier more on that later
don't worry about the new skill trees
spend those points when you first see
the learned skills menu in neo 2 it's
easy to get overwhelmed by the sheer
number of skill trees available don't
realistically you're only investing in a
few or so trees so try to take a moment
to decide early on which kind of
character you want to play to determine
which trees you ultimately want to use
do you want to focus primarily on
traditional samurai katana skills or
would you prefer to focus on on mule
magic and yokai powers consider what
interests you in which weapons you're
most comfortable with in battle and then
starts pecking your skill points from
there of course you're still free to
experiment and spec into as many skill
trees as you want but keep in mind once
you start settling on the kind of
character you want to be consider fully
respecting your stats and skill points
accordingly you can respect at any time
by purchasing the book of reincarnation
from the blacksmith who sets up shop at
the starting point after the second main
mission it costs ten thousand gold notes
so make sure you're 100% willing to take
the plunge before resetting since you're
frequently leveling up and increasing
your weapon proficiency early on you
quickly amass quite an abundance of
skill points check your skill tree often
to spend them on foundational abilities
within the skill trees of your choice
you should also occasionally dip into
your inventory to see if you found any
special locks of hair which can give you
free skill points of varying kinds upon
consumption these are incredibly handy
items that can be easy to neglect since
you're always picking up and earning so
much during your travels get running
water keep pulse ASAP
make sure to unlock the running water
key pulse techniques from the samurai
skill tree as soon as possible this
alternate key pulse technique allows you
to perform one with the precisely timed
dodge instead of the traditional method
of pressing r1 there are three running
water skills in total one for each
weapon stance so make sure to save up at
least six skill points to unlock them in
the samurai skill tree if you're having
trouble mastering the traditional key
pulse the running water key pulse can be
a great alternative the benefits of the
technique as the timing to execute
correctly is easier of course
do your best to master both key pulse
techniques as knowledge of each can
make you a far more effective fighter
let's talk yokai powers out of
everything the biggest new addition to
combat and neo2 is yokai powers which
help give you an offensive edge against
the insurmountable threats throughout
your journey as a half yokai human noon
is a shift link you can leverage your
supernatural abilities in a couple of
ways the first is through yokai shift a
powerful form you can transform into for
a limited time it's similar to neo ones
living weapon form but is greatly
expanded there are three yokai shift
forms in total brute feral and phantom
talking about their specific strengths
and weaknesses alone warrants its own
extensive guide but until I make one
know that brute is proficient for those
big on inflicting powerful melee damage
feral is fantastic for scrappy
hit-and-run tactics and phantom is for
more defensive minded on neo magic
players while the abilities of the three
yokai shift forms very subtly they all
share a common skill yokai burst when
timed correctly this technique can
interrupt encounter special enemy
attacks imbued with red energy leaving
your opponent open to attack the timing
varies with the enemy but try to execute
it just as their attack is about to hit
no sooner no later
it's also worth noting that the yokai
shift form you choose has its own unique
yokai burst and timing so make sure to
practice often against the different
enemy types be mindful that the
manoeuvre consumes anima energy which is
the purple gauge below your key so avoid
unnecessarily spamming it regardless
yokai burst is a significant pillar of
neo to combat and can quickly turn the
tide of a difficult encounter when used
intelligently soul cores 101
aside from yokai shift your yokai powers
also manifest in soul cores special
items collected from bosses and powerful
enemy youkai soul cores grant you
powerful attack abilities you can equip
up to two at a time so long as you have
enough capacity to attune it to your
guardian spirit each has a unique attack
for example the n key soul core quickly
turns you into that monkey yokai as you
throw a spirit at an enemy so cores
consume animal energy when performed so
try to be smart about when you choose to
unleash them in battle when you obtain a
soul core prioritize returning to read
nearby shrine to purify it as you lose
any in your possession if you die and
fail to retrieve your guardian spirit
grave it's possible to collect multiple
soul cores of the same type which you
can fuse at a shrine to increase the
potency of its special effects like most
things in the O - it's always good to
consolidate so make sure to use soul
fusion to improve your soul core power
otherwise you can use the resting rights
option to dispose of any unwanted
duplicates cluttering your inventory the
training ground if you're finding
yourself getting rekt more often than
not there's a practice space called the
training ground you can access it via
the starting point on the world map by
selecting dojo and then choosing the
training ground option here you can
comfortably test your weapons against a
handful of enemies as well as spend time
getting a handle on your yokai shift in
spirit core abilities it's a lovely
place to get your bearings but don't
rely on it missions have far more
diverse enemies to test your mettle
against that girl the dark realm
a new burden you'll face in neo2 is dark
realms imagine an area of a map that's
just all yokai roam
that's how dark realms are you need to
exercise caution whenever you enter a
dark realm yokai attacks are more
powerful and your key regeneration takes
a massive hit here and any shrines you
find are also inaccessible until the
area is purified to exorcise a dark
realm you need to defeat the main yokai
haunting the area you just need to be
extra diligent in the dark realm and
that means performing consistent key
pulses and knowing when to keep your
distance from powerful enemies to give
yourself enough time to replenish your
key don't rush luckily your animal
replenishes faster in the dark realm so
don't forget to lean on your yokai
abilities when your key is low be
careful in patient and you should rid
that area of all that debilitating
demonic Musk in no time if you're
willing to cheese it it's a sound
strategy to find more powerful yokai
have them follow you just outside the
dark realm and then kill them near the
entrance only do so before they have a
chance to teleport back though you're
welcome to rinse and repeat as their
health doesn't fully replenish upon
returning do not choose the bird
guardian spirit at the start you're
given the choice of a guardian spirit
which as mentioned dictates the yokai
form of your character you're free to
choose whichever but I highly recommend
not picking the bird guardian spirit I'm
a gnome authority which turns you into a
feral form since the guardian spirit you
earn for beating the first boss is
Massaro the monkey which can also turn
into a feral form so if you want to have
more yokai shift form options to play
with early on I suggest choosing either
Mikami the wolf or cog awanee
the shark benevolent graves and friends
as you explore Sengoku era japan you'll
discover benevolent graves which hold
the spirits of helpful AI controlled
allies they're similar to the hostile
revenant summons but instead of trying
to murder you
they follow you and provide support in
combat but their services don't come for
free
you need to expend an item called
ultracal cups which you can typically
find on dead bodies or get them from
defeating revenants it's also worth
noting that this item is used to summon
real-life players at a shrine of which
you can now have up to two join you so
try to be smart about when to spend them
to call upon the help of a benevolent
grave spirit depending on the challenge
you might be better off at the support
of a friend either way never let pride
get in the way of leaning on benevolent
graves especially in a pinch they can
easily throw off enemy aggression should
you need the time to breathe or flee
there in the game for a reason use those
tools spend your argue land in Gil
prestige points like the first game new
to has an internal achievement system
called the titles which allows you to
earn additional stat bonuses there are
two achievement lists in total ovule and
in Gil each contains several challenges
with distinct conditions for example the
dual swordsman hungee o title requires
you to defeat 30 human enemies with the
dual swords each titles list is hidden
at first so it helps to diversify the
attacks you use to increase your chances
of earning a new title and upon getting
that title you'll receive reputation
points and once you've accumulated
enough of those you'll gain a prestige
point which you can use to acquire a
stat bonus in the prestige summary
screen check your titles often so you
can further strengthen your character
Tom Rita memories if you're still
feeling confused about the copious
tutorials thrown at you early on you can
find comfort knowing that the Amrita
memory section of the pause screen
condenses and consolidates much of the
essential information around the games
mechanics for your reference you're free
to consult its entries for further
clarifications on anything that might
have perplexed you give yourself time to
thoroughly study them because chances
are you probably skip past more of those
tutorial screens than you should have
anyway got any more important neo2 tips
or questions about the game in general
let us know in the comments below thank
you so much for watching
[Music]